una nueva etapa estratégica entre España
y Brasil así empezó el presidente del
gobierno español Pedro Sánchez su
comparecencia tras reunirse con el
presidente de Brasil y Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva en su viaje por Europa Lula
combina objetivos de política interior y
exterior desde la búsqueda de nuevas
oportunidades con el que es el segundo
inversor en el gigante sudamericano para
impulsar la economía hasta reforzar
alianzas para proteger la amazonía o
Buscar soluciones a la guerra en Ucrania
ambos gobiernos tienen por delante
importantes tareas España por su parte
presidirá el consejo de la Unión Europea
desde julio al mismo tiempo que Brasil
ahora lo propio con mercosur quieren por
tanto estrechar lazos entre los
continentes y dejar atrás el aislamiento
impulsado por bolsonaro el objetivo es
lograr avances hacia el acuerdo
comercial entre ambos bloques pendiente
desde 2019 en la visita se firmaron
varios memorandos de entendimiento y
acuerdos en temas de trabajo de la
ciencia o de la educación Pero más allá
de los temas bilaterales con esta gira
Lula pretende ganar apoyos en occidente
para impedir que se opte más por el
diálogo y la mediación para que termine
la guerra en Ucrania el brasileño
propone crear el g20 de la paz y crítico
a países del Consejo de Seguridad de la
ONU por ser los principales proveedores
de armas y por seguir invadiendo
naciones Sánchez en este punto dejó
Claro que hay un país agresor y un país
agredido el presidente de Brasil
finalizará su visita a España con un
encuentro y un almuerzo con Los Reyes en
el Palacio real y se espera que la
semana que viene mantenga una
conversación telefónica con el
presidente de Francia Emmanuel macron